on se baigne un 28 décembre à Biarritz
cela fait 10 jours maintenant que les
températures sont particulièrement
douces aujourd'hui il y a même du soleil
mes chaussettes
et j'ai mis un gros pull
et un t-shirt on préfère passer la
journée à la mer sous la pluie que
devant la télé à la maison c'est même
incroyable on a même pas les bonnes
affaires on pensait qu'il allait faire
vraiment plus frais
on se retrouve en suite tout le temps
j'aime bien faire des trous dans le
sable et
on va s'envoler là non
les commerçants en profitent ouais c'est
sûr ça mène du monde mais il y a
toujours des températures comme ça bien
en hiver ouais c'est incroyable je crois
que le dernier c'était un peu pareil et
là où l'hôtellerie la restauration est
pas encore opérationnel par rapport à
cette nouvelle façon de travailler c'est
à dire je suis en freelance je travaille
4 heures chez l'un une journée chez
l'autre j'ai mes clients je peux avoir
comme client un restaurant chez qui je
travaille 4 heures un autre hôtel chez
qui je travaille trois heures dans la
cuvée 99 vous touchez peut-être des
allocs votre Bamba a parfois besoin d'un
doudou qui peut arriver pile poil pile
poil c'est aussi dans le dictionnaire
l'hôtellerie et la restauration est
encore dans un ancien modèle ou elle est
pas adaptée à ce nouveau mode de vie et
de travail auquel les gens aspirent pas
forcément que les jeunes mais aussi les
quadras les trentenaires etc alors là
j'ai Florent Mariotte est-ce que ça veut
dire ah bah là j'ai non c'est quand on
fait quelque chose que c'est c'est notre
cas par exemple on a mal répondu c'est
la gênance et comme menuisier peut
fabriquer des ascenseurs
[Applaudissements]
non
pourquoi
maintenant non mais d'accord on m'avez
dit que c'était pas forcément en bois
qu'on était menuisier
c'est quand même assez particulier des
normes de sécurité c'est plus des
sociétés qui font ça maintenant
j'ai essayé de vous trouver du boulot
vous voyez dans ce restaurant la
direction a pris les devants la
vaisselle réutilisable est déjà prête
depuis un mois pour Anastasia Brisset
directrice de site chez Burger and
friends c'est un atout pour attirer de
nouveaux clients publier il y a quelques
jours par le site gastronomique test
atlas de nombreuses internautes du monde
entier ce sont demandés si cette liste
était une blague un peu plus loin dans
ce kebab rien n'est prêt et ce pour une
raison simple j'étais pas au courant
alors que l'Italie s'offre la première
place la France est classée 9e derrière
des États-Unis ce qui en a scandalisé
plus d'un certains se demandent qui
gèrent le compte
d'autres en profitent pour nous rappeler
à quoi ressemble la 8e meilleure cuisine
du du monde histoire d'être sûr de nous
couper l'appétit
en 2016 à l'occasion d'un voyage au
Vietnam Barack Obama en personne s'est
arrêtée dans cet échec à Hanoï pour en
déguster je me suis retrouvé face à lui
j'étais très impressionné et on était
très sympa très gentil vraiment adorable
on a échangé quelques mots il m'a sauté
une très bonne année parce qu'on était
au mois de janvier je l'avais dit
j'attendais judo je vais me contenter de
pirates voici la table ou le président
Obama a mangé c'était le 23 mai 2016
j'ai mis cette table sous verre pour que
nous en gardions un souvenir si je ne
l'avais pas fait on aurait fini par
mélanger cette table avec les autres on
est super content que vous soyez là
expliquez-nous je suis allé voir 204
fois Kaamelott premier volet au cinéma
dans le but de battre encore du monde
qui était de Avengers pour 191 fois
bravo j'ai apporté mais en petit
ukulélé
regardez vous allez pouvoir noter ma
chérie et Yohan
pour le rappeler quand même parce qu'au
cinéma on est assis
c'est il y a aussi une préparation
physique sport tous les matins Dominique
jamais peut-être un mot sur le l'ancien
pape Benoît X qui est gravement malade
comment savez le projet un catholique
professionnel
c'est à 18h30 lundi soir que quelque
passant tente de dissuader Mohamed de
sauterallo en vain l'homme est déterminé
quelques minutes avant sur ses réseaux
sociaux il avait publié une vidéo où il
explique les raisons de son acte quand
vous regardez cette vidéo je ne sais pas
vivre
il était justement à ce moment-là je
décide
pour montre tout le monde pour nu
iranienne besoin d'aide
[Musique]
jolie
dans cette vidéo celui qui vit à Lyon
depuis 3 ans avec sa femme dit aussi se
suicider sans aucun stress ni tristesse
une sérénité qui suscite l'admiration
Shayan a participé à plusieurs
manifestations contre le régime avec
Mohamed je l'admire pour ce qu'il a fait
il a donné ce qu'il avait plus cher au
monde pour que la cause des Iraniens
soit défendu que la voix désiraniens
soit entendue hier soir c'est proche lui
rendait un dernier hommage avec des
champs
et ce slogan
des femmes uniquement bonnes à faire des
enfants à nettoyer la maison ou être des
épouses attentionnées c'est dans quelle
série Un gars une fille
on n'a pas vu les mêmes épisodes alors
non c'est elve mail le servante écarlate
1968 Barbie a une amie noire donc c'est
Christie
2022 enfin elle change de silhouette
n'est plus au test l'air mais pilote
l'avion Ken n'a qu'à faire le steward